eine impfstudie an der universität
oxford stimmt jetzt zuversichtlich auf
ein baldiges ende der pandemie
denn forscher in england sprechen jetzt
von äußerst vielversprechenden
ergebnissen bei 1077 personen für führte
die injektion des mittels dazu dass sie
antikörper bildeten und t zellen die das
cora virus dann bekämpfen können
kommt der korona impfstoff jetzt also
doch schon schneller als gedacht
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
dem biologen dr martin stimme mir nun
auch zugeschaltet und morgen herr doktor
stürmer sagen sie uns ist das jetzt also
der große durchbruch diese forschungen
in oxford das ist auf jeden fall eine
sehr wichtige gute nachricht für die
impfstoffforschung denn die sogenannte
phase 3 studie ist die letzte klinische
studie vor der zulassung und viele viele
substanzen schaffen ist meistens gar
nicht glaubt in die klinische prüfung
insofern eine gute nachricht für uns
alle weil das heißt nämlich dass der
impfstoff in den ersten phasen das
gezeigt hat was er zeigen soll nämlich
eine gute wirkung und so wenig nehmen
wir unmöglich heißt es der impfstoff
kommt jetzt für alle viel schneller es
wird ja viel darüber spekuliert wann wir
damit rechnen können könnte es dann
schon dieses jahr soweit sein
dieses jahr wäre ich vorsichtig mit der
aussicht dass es dieses jahr noch
passiert wäre ich vorsichtig die phase 3
ist die größte studie fordert zulassung
es werden an mehreren tausenden
patienten getestet und letztlich wusste
ich doch jetzt im feld zeigen dass er
wirklich vor infektionen schützt das
heißt man muss auch ausreichende anzahl
von patienten haben die ein risiko
ausgesetzt worden sind und dann muss
ausgewertet werden inwieweit
anschutz bestanden hat vor der infektion
und um diese zahl der events zu bekommen
werde einige monate vergehen
da muss die studie ausgewertet werden
insofern wäre ich vorsichtig dazu lassen
in diesem jahr ein sondern jetzt ein
zeitplan sieht als nächstes wird der
impfstoff jetzt an vielen vielen
menschen getestet und was muss denn noch
passieren damit er auf den markt kommt
ja der ist doch muss jetzt zeigen dass
er tatsächlich wird das heißt wir müssen
menschen haben die dem virus ausgesetzt
worden sind und sich nicht angesteckt
haben im vergleich zu einer
kontrollgruppe die nicht geimpft worden
ist und das muss man auswerten diese
ganze anzahl an patienten und muss das
zeigen da muss die statistiken darüber
laufen diese daten müssen an die
behörden weitergereicht werden und die
behörden entscheiden dann ob die
substanz eben zugelassen werden kann
oder nicht
und dieses interview mit dr stürmer
haben wir bereits vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet